aux canards
[Musique]
elle est incroyable elle s'appelle
mélanie sinon et je vous demande de les
faire un accueil phénoménal merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
ok
bonsoir
non parce que je suis venu en fait parce
que j'ai lu mon horoscope ce matin et ça
m'a dit vas dans la lumière
bon ça va être long
bah alors je vais me présenter
alors je suis juive à moitié tunisienne
et polonaise
je suis né en 31 octobre halloween à 17
heures l'heure du goûter
voilà ça fait que j'ai déjà pas mal de
névrose sinon je m'appelle mélanie ça
vient du grec enfermer la noce ça veut
dire sombre ils y perdraient que si vous
voulez passer un agréable moment il
suffit de passer quelques instants avec
une mélanie une personne charmante et
souriante
[Musique]
on considère les mails années comme une
hyperactive
c'est vrai que c'est au mac cela
alors je me suis dit entre monroe scop
et je m'appelle mélanie fonce dans la
lumière
oui moi j'aime bien lire l'horoscope ça
que je suis quelqu'un de très mais
parfois c'est un peu embêtant
il ya deux jours j'ai lu mon horoscope
il y avait marqué franchise et confiance
j'ai vu mon patron je lui ai dit tu es
un gros con je suis sous payé il m'a dit
tu as raison tu es viré
voilà c'est con c'est dommage parce que
c'est leur scot du lendemain j'ai lu
réfléchissez prenez du recul avant de
foncer tête baissée
c'était un peu trop tard du coup on
cherche du travail alors je suis
autonome et dynamique là ce matin par
exemple j'ai lu dans mon horoscope que
j'allais être très perturbé en même
temps je viens de me faire gérer et j'ai
200 personnes devant moi alors je en
amour ça disait que j'aurai un gros coup
de coeur il n'y est donc pas forcément
solide mais bien agréable
alors je suis déjà marié je sais pas si
je dois prévenir mon mari je vais avoir
un amant du coup niveau argent ça disait
que j'aurai du flair pour les bonnes
affaires
alors ça c'est pas mal parce que du coup
en plus d'avoir un amant je vais tomber
sur un groupe fusion mais du coup ça
fait deux informations à donner à mon
mari je passerai mais ça je le savais
c'est à cause de mon premier décan non
mais parce que je suis juste scorpion
ascendant délier et j'avais dit à mon
mari quand je les ai rencontrés il ya
dix ans alors bonjour je m'appelle
mélanie j'ai un capital sympathie je
suis généreuse j'adore communiqué voilà
mais lui il a pris ça pour acquis
et là ça fait cinq ans qu'on bien
ensemble il sait toujours pas où est
rangé de sel c'est pas mal parce que ces
chemises sait toujours pas où est la
machine à laver alors je dis oui ok
d'accord j'ai un capital sympathie mais
vous oubliez pas que j'ai mon marsan
poisson alors je sais pas prendre de
décision ferme 1 et je suis complètement
innocent inattendu mais bon et puis en
plus j'ai mal lu d'un cancer alors je
suis hyper émotive
voilà ah ben ça a pas loupé il ya trois
ans s'est marié pour les faire par
moncler les faire-part blanc crème non
non non non c'est pas du tout la même
chose blanc c'est blanc crème ces crèmes
non c'est une nuance
non non le crème c'est par un blanc qui
tire sur le jaune non non c'est pas non
plus un blanc qui tient sur le sable non
non c'est pas du tout la même chose tu
fais comme si je te disais typographie
enfoncée ou un relief nuance ou c'est
comme si je te disais pas été ou briand
nuance non non je suis pas du tout
énervé mais bon c'est un petit pas gays
sont quand même
non non non non mais c'est non mais
j'aimerais juste que tu t'impliques un
petit peu dans ce mariage tu vois un
petit un petit 2 blanc crème voilà oui
non pourquoi conclusion non mais moi ça
me fait un garçon comme amarger
impression que tu comprends pas trop
quand je parle alors que j'ai quand même
la reine de la communication au malawi
c'est mon horoscope qu'il le dit un oui
non mais si tu pouvais nager cette
playstation aussi s'il te plaît non mais
c'est aussi comme pour les photos de
famille je vais pas les faire toutes
seules les photos de famille parce que
dans photos familiales aux familles et
amis c'est ce qu'on est sensé fondé avec
le mot mariage
oui c'est un petit peu agaçant quand
même oui bien sûr un petit peu en train
de mourir oui oui oui oui oui
alors là par contre je vais te dire une
fois pas de oui là c'est une menace
ainsi tabac envie d'enchaîner sur un
divorce direct par un terrain tu
appliques et fissa fissa dans
l'organisation de ce [__] de merde de
mariage de mes rêves
voilà où vas tu savais j'ai quand même
mon [__] au scorpion tu savais que
j'avais une violence enfui à moi qui
peut sortir avec une intensité inouïe
oui moi aussi je t'aime
[Musique]
je l'avais prévenu voilà mais ça ça
apparemment selon le forum 14 12 89 de
doctissimo
j'ai donné trop tôt de deux mauvaises
habitudes à mon mari en étant trop
gentil à moi j'y crois c'est for a man
oui il ya plein plein plein de bons
conseils
moi c'est comme ça que j'ai appris que
j'avais un potentiel qui stocker va
toujours là en fait j'avais un peu mal
au dos et en plus j'avais lu mon
horoscope qui avait marqué santé bof bof
du coup bah ouais il s'est avéré que
j'ai eu mes règles juste une heure après
mais bon moi c'était patoune tigre et du
93 qui m'avait conseillé de faire un
check up quand même oui ou non mais vous
rigolez mais vous serez bien content
quand vous errez sur ces sites et que
vous aurez mal au pied droit et moi je
serai peut-être la selle mais l'ani 94
qu'on le prouve c'est moi je serai
peut-être la seule à vous conseiller de
faire un check up à ce que vous aurez
peut-être un ulcère à l'estomac par d'un
pied ça va lui bon on n'est jamais trop
prudent
du coup comme je discute souvent avec
pato intégrée du 93 moi il m'a dit que
j'avais sûrement une intolérance à
l'optimisme parce que je n'arrivais pas
à avoir d'enfant c'est logique parce que
ça fait trois ans que j'essaye d'avoir
un enfant avec mon mari et moi je
m'étais dit aussi c'est long il a
vraiment un horoscope de merde
en même temps je les savais toro
scorpions je le savais mais j'ai voulu
lui donner une chance
voilà en plus on fait tout le temps
l'amour bah oui parce que j'ai jemma
venus en balance alors j'ai tout le
temps envie enfin une vraie l'info de
manu partout partout tout le temps je me
disais quand même au bout de trois ans
c'est long entre l'horoscope et ça j'ai
fini par aller voir un gynéco et il m'a
dit madame vaut aux verts ils sont comme
du gruyère
c'est dommage parce que j'aime beaucoup
de pros mages
alors alors bon c'est elle ou trois ans
en plus quand il m'a dit ça j'avais une
caméra dans le vagin ce jour-là
l'horoscope mama encore d'y aller dans
la lumière
je savais pas d'où elles allaient venir
me fallait bien commencer par un endroit
c'est vrai que cette lumière est quand
même plus agréable
bon bah du coup je sais pas trop quoi
faire avec cette histoire d'amour c'est
un peu perturbant pas du coup je je vais
peut-être prendre du recul cette fois-ci
manquer
[Applaudissements]
mais n'hésite pas c'est la mélamine
moneda bonsoir mélanie sont joints
belani bon bah oui c'est vrai oui c'est
ça très bien mais l'a dit alors est ce
que tu peux nous dire un mot clic
tétouan est ce que tu peux nous dire où
on peut te voir en ce moment ton
actualité comment on peux te retrouver
alors ben comme j'ai plus de boulot pour
l'instant vous pouvez me voir chez moi
j'aime tu regardais un anniversaire ou
quelque chose qu'on pourrait venir
je lis l'horoscope des gens si ça vous
intéresse
voilà bah oui c'est intéressant c'est
très intéressant là et sinon tu fais des
scènes ouvertes l'instant j'ai écrit mon
seul en scène mais ça prend un peu de
temps parce que comme je l'écris en
fonction de mon horoscope
oui oui oui oui oui non et aujourd'hui
des equato horoscope
je ne connais pas par coeur a alors ma
citation d'aujourd'hui c'est le salut de
l'homme et de la sincérité
le salut peut être que je suis doit
encore salué mélanie vous gouverneur la
pâte et ouais merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
magog
battus
[Musique]
ban